con nuestro segundo invitado el día
vamos a hablar de la inflación a nivel
mundial que está afectando a muchos o
países obviamente no todos por igual
pero la mayoría sobre todo nuestro
continente y nuestra nuestra nuestro
continente y también pues nuestra región
de América Latina y el Caribe hemos
visto sobre todo en los precios de los
alimentos la guerra en Ucrania
evidentemente uno de los principales
detonantes para todo esto que está
ocurriendo con la subida de los precios
a nivel global saludamos entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado el día él es
Claudio loser el expresidente de la
consultora centenia el América Latina y
exdirector para el hemisferio occidental
del fondo monetario internacional el fmi
Claudio Gracias por estar con nosotros
en directo América de France 24 como
siempre Un gusto conversar con usted
para la explicación de todos estos temas
a tan complicados o no conversamos a
unos meses atrás de la mano de nuestra
compañera de economía Daniela Blandón
sobre esta inflación si mal no recuerdo
también estábamos conversando sobre el
alto precio del dólar para nosotros o
para nuestra región de América Latina
del Caribe pero en nivel Macro como ve
la inflación a nivel internacional y
para usted Le quiero preguntar cuál es
el cuál ha sido el principal detonante
bien evidentemente estamos frente a una
tasa de inflación que no habíamos
experimentado en mucho mucho tiempo
aquellos de nosotros que peinamos canas
o menos canas recordamos por supuesto la
inflación de los años ochenta que
realmente fue peor que esta pero desde
entonces en la mayoría de los países
digamos no ha habido tasas de inflación
tan altas Eh no voy a mencionar el caso
de Venezuela el caso de Argentina y
algunos más que tienen características
muy digamos endémicas voy a dejar estas
de lado evidentemente la inflación que
vivimos hoy es que los economistas a
nivel Macro
tratan de reducir
es tremendamente
negativa para toda la población y fue
causada aunque le echan la culpa de
alguna manera
a la Guerra de Ucrania que tuvo o la
guerra la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania eh
eso ha tenido mucho que ver pero también
venía de antes porque en el año 2020
cuando tuvimos Esta caída tan brutal en
la economía
las maquinitas impresoras de billetes y
puedo ponerlo de esta manera eh
funcionaron Muy fuertemente en Estados
Unidos en Japón en Europa y menos en
nuestros países en digamos en América
Latina Pero eso todo se acumuló pero
realmente
pasó a ser gravísimo
[Música]
Durante este año
la inflación a nivel mundial se espera
que llegue en el año 2022 a casi 10%
en los países
en Estados Unidos se piensa que va a ser
siete por ciento en Europa el nueve por
ciento en América Latina puede ser hasta
14% anual un poquito menos si uno saca
la los países como Argentina y Venezuela
evidentemente
el corte en el petróleo y el corte en
los alimentos fueron el gatillo que
llevaron a esto sin embargo tengo que
decir que hoy hoy en día el petróleo a
nivel mayorista si puedo ponerlo de esta
manera
internacionalmente está
igual que antes de la Guerra de Ucrania
hemos visto alguna reducción y yo creo
que esto va a tener un efecto positivo y
para terminar la idea Por supuesto está
todo el tema que los bancos centrales
que son los malvados en esta situación
junto con el fondo monetario
internacional pero que son los que los
dentistas que ayudan a solucionar el
dolor
han trabajado muy fuerte y
están ayudando a reducir la inflación
Claudio y se suma nuestra conversación
nuestra cronista de economía Daniela
blanndona Daniela tiene usted la palabra
Hola Claudio un placer saludarlo de
nuevo
bueno Pues precisamente sobre ese punto
que usted mencionaba de los bancos
centrales da la sensación o es bueno
explicarle a la gente que las decisiones
que toman los bancos centrales no tienen
un inmediato porque acá por ejemplo le
va a dar un ejemplo Colombia tenemos una
inflación altísima tasas de interés
altísimas y todavía no se ve cómo esa
inflación empieza a bajar a pesar de que
las tasas están subiendo Cómo hacer para
entender este fenómeno de que nos están
poniendo tasas más altas Pero la
inflación no baja Bueno
yo haría un paralelo no técnico que
[Música]
se hable del dentista es muy feo hablar
de eso que
los bancos centrales son como los
dentistas o como los cirujanos tienen
que operar Pero el efecto primero es
dolor y solamente después de algunos
meses uno ve el resultado y es terrible
o sea
es muy difícil entender incluso
para los economistas que dicen Bueno hay
que
[Música]
hay que ir al Banco Central subir las
tasas de interés esto por supuesto va a
ser más costoso los préstamos esto puede
mejorar nuestra moneda pero es difícil a
veces entender cuánto demora el proceso
se piensa que entre seis meses y un año
es terrible claro
es fundamentalmente lo que
la forma que funciona hay que tener
paciencia Lamentablemente y apoyar a
aquellos países o aquellas
digamos grupos de la población que son
más afectados paciencia qué es lo que
nos falta muchísimo no Daniela sí señor
y también paciencia para nosotros que
somos los que finalmente vemos nuestro
bolsillo afectado y quería preguntarle
si usted cree que también hay un factor
de especulación de precios porque
en varios países ya se habla de eso en
Venezuela van a empezar a imponer
controles de precios Usted cree que se
han aprovechado de alguna manera los la
cadena productiva toda esta situación
para subir precios sin causa alguna
Mire yo como
argentino nativo tengo que decir de que
por experiencia no profesional sino
personal de que hay mucho de eso se
inflan porque se tiene miedo que la
inflación suba pero yo diría que ese es
un efecto
es un efecto
transitorio O sea la parte de inflación
que está dada por el impacto
internacional el caso de en todos los
países latinoamericanos Colombia por
ejemplo ha sufrido más en estos tiempos
que mucho antes el impacto digamos es
generar pero fundamentalmente después
[Música]
digamos lo que lo que importa es que Se
imprime mucho dinero
y que se importa la inflación la parte
negativa no puede durar demasiado puede
crear problemas pero a la larga sí las
políticas monetarias funcionan esto es
un globo que se pincha quizás sea esto
una expresión de deseo pero es mi
impresión que va a pasar